okay so this is the chart of basically
dating options based on age so you can't
see it because it's it's basically 23
it's a woman's Peak we're about 38 is a
man's Peak
and that's basically your value in the
marketplace based on how many options
you have to the opposite sex so you'll
see around
um can you put your mouse over where 35
is
okay
yeah so that's the compared to men where
theirs goes up and so this is just
something that I see with older couples
when they do get divorced the men end up
getting remarried because they have more
of a leverage in the marketplace where
the women don't
yeah that explains why there's a lot
more yeah older guys dating like I've
got a lot of friends that are dating
that around my age 23 24 dating guys
that are like in their 30s and it's
working yeah
I prefer dating guys in their 30s
um and the because when women are over
the age of like I think it's 50 they
have a 25 like
I think there's I'm gonna butcher this
but it's basically like men under the
age of like 30 have a 25 chance of being
in a relationship and it flips after
like age 55 or 50. right
um see like from my mom she has the
options of having someone in her life
but she just chooses not to because I
think she I think what she went through
with my dad was more than enough like to
start over and have those kind of
concerns okay would he be cheating I
think she's just like actually I can do
battle by myself like you don't think
she'd prefer to be with a man she loves
and respects over being by herself like
if she could pick one of the two but
then it also goes back to like and you
know when we date we always always have
these kind of things okay is he gonna be
faithful what's his history for her to
start that all over again for her it's
like nah because there is a 90 chance
that he's lying or he's there's a 90
chance yes that he's a lion he's a
cheater absolutely so 90 of men you
think are liars and cheaters to stop
back at that age and I'm saying that
because I know of people in her in her
age group that are not that they were
divorced but they're dating again and
it's just kind of like you know they're
with people who don't add value to their
life like no they don't appreciate them
in confidence and stuff like that and
they just settled but they're unhappy
but that's the point of the graph is
that like they can't get the best people
anymore because they're older um no like
I know someone who's been with someone
for unlike early 50s who's been with
someone for more than 10 years and
they're not happy but they're afraid of
letting go of that because they have to
start all over again but they're not
happy but I think we have a tendency
sorry saying that 90 that you said not
we can't that and I get the situation
and I get sometimes it can be that
trauma stays there but you can't then
base every man off of people that you
know and I think we have a tendency of
doing that in terms of that percentage I
don't think is right because there are
men out there that are willing to start
again there are men out there that have
been cheated on for 10 years by their
their wife if there are men out there
that have had to go through trauma with
children to say you know there are men
out there that share the same types of
stories that us women do the the
difference is we're a lot more vocal
about it because we don't have to take
accountability in a sense the way
Society is made you know things to be
where men it's like okay but if she did
cheat on you it's like but what did you
do was you there for her did you do this
for her it's like we're making excuses
why she was cheating on him but if we
say oh a man was cheating on us it's
like oh he had that right yeah I mean
and the other thing is we don't talk
about women's part to playing cheating
I'm not I don't know your story
personally but one out of four marriages
is sexless one out of four so if you're
not sleeping with your husband you're
surprised someone else is yeah exactly
it's not even some men just love
cheating like no some you're right just
some do but it's a small percentage of
men that can cheat most most men one out
of three men under 30 are either sexless
or virgins
it's because we're all going for a small
percentage of men look it do you guys do
you guys think this room are we top ten
percent of women
in the world out of every 10 women top
10 as a group instead of finances no
looks I'll put myself there don't mind
me today hello yeah I'm getting here in
the top she could look like a movie star
in a minute do you think you're you're
top ten percent I just said that yeah no
no you're not that's your opinion I mean
I'm not trying to be here
and Brianna came from the island next to
me okay without money come on let's just
not no money has a lot to eat yeah look
at Rihanna at eight come on I'm not
saying you're bad looking but I'm not
taking it as that Rihanna you think
you're at the same level as Rihanna yeah
call me delusional like that website but
I do literally what what makes a woman
what what makes you value Rihanna
um in a thin I mean I mean I wouldn't
say she's I wouldn't say she's a 10
um now because she's a bit older but I
would say when she was 22 I would put
her at a nine or ten um because she was
young
um she was thin she was tall she looked
like a model very symmetrical face yeah
I think it's wonderful that you feel
like that about yourself and I think
every woman should feel like that yeah
absolutely but when we do look at
objectively it's like would it be all of
us out here or would it be Margot Robbie
and Rihanna and you know what I mean I
think they're like
well tons tons have ten outcomes so you
either have modeling contracts or nines
nines and tenses so we're going by size
basically because everything has to do
with size modeling contract size
who even like we're overcome getting it
guys like just who get the most
attention by men if you're walking down
the street
and I mean like in terms of attention
like oh okay like I'd want to take her
home like she's wifey material not just
all she's got a big fake butt yeah
that's what she's talking about but then
we talk about okay I get you but we talk
about size and then you're like size and
big butt you get it like no but we're
just talking about like attractive just
yeah just looks not personality you know
what else you could bring to the table
Yeah be in the table like actually just
pure looks like what made the final
attract top ten percent so is that the
only thing that men look for on women
that's what it starts with she's just
asking about look sir yeah for this
particular question no I understand I
just I assumed that the point you're
making was like the a lower percentage
of women are going for the Tottenham
salad man and so do we think we're the
top 10 women but then that's obviously
basing it on the fact that men are only
looking at looks and not the other
things men do look at other things but
it starts with looks you have to be over
a certain threshold for Matt yeah
we all come from different backgrounds
and cultures so where I come from I'm
valued highly as a woman as a black
woman it's only when we integrate
ourselves like for example I use my
example of coming to England where
there's a whole bunch of different
aspects on what men think is beautiful I
always remember when I went to a reggae
concert and
um there's this guy he bounced into me a
Rasta and he was like sorry empress and
it I was like oh shoot like I was like
why did that make me feel
like really respected and I was like
I've forgotten that that's what I grew
up with it's only when I come here that
it's you know there's a sort of
disrespect in how women are greeted in
the Caribbean you're greeted like
Empress Queen you know and it's not just
words they value you so when I come here
and I have to look at Beauty stands and
size and other than that there's no
brain it's like a western half of these
women who are how long were you there
till how old um high school so I was
there until 17 18. 18. so that's like
yeah so when I come over here and then
you have different cultures who tell you
what beauty standards are and like what
you should accept that's just hair and
let me tell you England has a lot of
influence you have Instagram I do okay
nines and tens get nines and tens
outcomes on Instagram they could be an
Eastern Europe or Russia but the the
rich men will find them what are they
showing though to get that attention I I
look at sometimes it's sexual you know
sometimes it's that but but beautiful
come on a girl that looks like Margot
Robbie I don't even know what that is if
she just showed um who's another one
Rihanna at 22. they would find her yeah
yeah they were in London absolutely but
look at the ages that we're comparing
their beauty and we're speaking about
them now we're saying Rihanna when she
was in her 20s but Rihanna's like
but this I think she's 36 years yeah but
yeah that's where you're gonna go go off
the graph yeah okay
I find it more attractive she was a nine
at 22. yeah I don't know so she's like a
six seven six seven seven it's because
she's got a kid now that she's devalued
yeah they say that you know yeah to Matt
to men um a kid subtracts two points so
if you're an eight and you have a kid
each kid is two points
but then also Society tells us that as
women because of like how men mature
that we need to go for older guys yeah
and so it's the sort of thing where half
half the people I know they'll want a
guy like 10 years is
but can start at 10 years older and so
it's just kind of like and it's not
maybe financially they're more stable
but in terms of how they get treated yes
probably a little bit better because
they've had that life where they've had
kids so there's no pressure for them to
have kids or there's more of a financial
stability they probably own a house by
then you know but
there's different things you know but I
think it's about like the Western
Community though because I think what
you're going to look for I mean I'm
Jamaican like what you're going to look
for in the Caribbean is different to
what the stats would be like over here
you know we're part of like a Western
Community in terms of men are like I
don't think yeah I disagree with that I
think I think beauty is just crazy I
know what you mean like yes we do
slightly you know you do yeah there's a
slight difference but I think a very
good looking girl I'm saying like men
and women though I'm saying like for
example like what I'm saying is we're
not being in terms of what you're saying
in terms of beauty and stuff I'm saying
like I would disagree with you in terms
of we're not being realistic on like you
said what I'm what a man would actually
gravitate to if that's or highly
gravitate to because that the 20 of men
I mean in that 20 I don't think much of
them are going to be tubby do you know
what I mean I think they're going to be
quite athletic or masculine in that way
do you know what I mean something in
terms of being realistic I agree with
you in a sense where there there's a
certain type of woman that men would
gravitate to more my only point was that
everyone here who had the highest
percentage 20 percent
like when we did the delusion calculator
what was it who had the highest
percentages and you picked what was it
20 yes 15 yeah I picked 15 and it came
up to 13.8 okay yeah 13 that so out of
us we're all we're all competing for up
to 13 of guys would you say that you're
in the top 10 of women though because
what you've disc what you've described
in the podcast is like what makes an
attractive woman is like slim you're
slim you've got a symmetrical face you
have feminine features and you've got
long hair you wear dresses like so what
makes you not
about 10
um
I I think I'm cute but I don't I don't
think I'm the top 10 of facial symmetry
um I think I could probably lose a
little weight you know um I think you
could I've seen you'll cook things you
have lost weight you look great thank
you thank you thank you I did see your
Chef things on on Twitter yeah no um
I've lost a bit of weight but no I mean
I think it'd be quite delusional to say
I'm in the top temper like if I'm
looking at Margot Robbie and Rihanna at
22 do I think that I compete with them
and we're going to be talking to the
same men no no I I and I don't think
that's a bad thing to say that most
people are average I don't think there's
anything wrong with just being an
average person but do you want the do
you want a mat as a six foot woman do
you want a mountain taller than you do
you do you describe ideally but um I
don't mind if they're a bit shorter but
you settle
um I wouldn't I wouldn't say subtle um I
think that settling implies that like
you somehow don't deserve what you get I
think you always deserve what you get
like I think if you deserve if if you
qualify for the top 10 percent of men
you'll get them and if you haven't got
them you don't qualify I think you can
get info thank you I appreciate that a
lot of men don't even want a 10 anyway
we want like a nice seven or eight like
a really good looking girl but not super
arrogant and self-conceited in all the
things that tend to come with the most
attractive girl so there's no shame in
not being in the top ten percent or
being a ten like I don't understand why
it has to be like a little girl oh I'm a
tear yeah it's like no you're still a
great person you're still a good looking
girl it's fine you don't have to be a 10
you can feel a ten but it doesn't mean
like you know I agree with you but it's
I think and I completely understand but
it's like who are you to tell someone
they're not attend like I'm not not not
not being disrespectful not in that but
I'm just in conversation like
it's all raised on what we were told is
a 10. especially in today's beauty
standards you know so we can't be picky
and choosy because people are who they
are in terms of tens five six I think
they have to live in reality though like
I think like a lot of times as women
like we just live in delusion and we're
never told the truth ever and I I think
it's it's quite delusional to to think
that I'm on the same level as Rihanna I
think that's delusional well I'm told
the truth I've grown on that so yeah I'd
say I'm definitely told the truth like
if I'm like I'm a dancer if I do a dance
my dad's gonna tell me I need to go on
train I mean if I'm putting on a bit of
weight they're gonna tell me to go get
in that gym girl so I've always been
told the truth I think that's why I just
reality is reality you can't fight it in
it my mom tells me the truth all the
time like she but it's the way she does
it but she tells me the truth all the
time so
but we just have to this isn't another
topic but beauty standards like what who
are we to say beauty is this you know
like I agree if you if you're with your
woman and you choose your woman right to
you she's a 10. so other people she's
not but for you men just lie
do men lie yes women men like to get
books no but if you have your woman
would you I don't I I don't lie about
men do you lie so you don't lie about
your man so are you no I don't lie
because I you know if if I was gonna go
out to go I find her attractive yeah I
mean yeah but a lot of men do lie and
try to say the sweetest when you said
Jamaican I thought bloody oh you're
gonna say Ireland boys island boys are
the most promiscuous let's be honest
they're saying that Queens
they love a pillow talk you gotta look
at them ladies
they have the werewolves yeah they do I
don't even think like I feel like beauty
standards there's just hot and not hot
that's my opinion I don't think I think
most men
will look at every every race and just
hot or not hot in general yeah then
you're not then I agree I've never
worried about that then like my
my partner is probably in the top
percentage of and that he earns well he
buys me nice bags he takes me nice
places he's six foot three
but obviously I didn't know what he
looked like before I met him but like
I've never struggled and like I'm
overweight like I'm not the best looking
woman in the world Margot Robbie could
absolutely take me in a beauty pageant
100 times good for you but like I've
never struggled with that I think
there's so much more to it it's about
like your circles and who you're around
and but you're like you're not married
no I don't want to be right now but I'm
saying the outcome is marriage that most
women are looking for yeah so you
haven't really won till you're married
that's an interesting way to look at
relationships though I mean I would just
okay do you do you think that marriage
is above a relationship like yeah it's
more committed but I do I don't want
that commitment right now okay and
that's fine no no problem
yeah I don't think it is though that's
but I you don't think you'd have an
easier time if you were thinner
I think that I've always done so I've
been thin and I've always done well I
did better in entertainment when I was
thinner 100 yeah because I was more
attractive and so I got more actually so
if they pulled the top 10 20 of men and
they took a picture of you heavier and
thinner which one would they pick
typically thinner but that doesn't mean
that it's held me back I'm not saying
you can't it can't happen but I think I
just haven't struggled and what I'm
trying to add well I mean you're a
pretty girl you know I mean yeah I mean
I'm not so I'm I'm not saying that you
can't have that outcome I just think if
we're going on a balance of
probabilities you have a modeling
contract right yeah so that means at
least facially you're above average yeah
well plus size modeling correct and so
like that worked out for you because
you're a pretty girl but most women are
average most people are not above
average
yeah so of course you're going to
struggle less
you disagree with that no I no
moving on
um would you are you with an overweight
guy no no okay would you would you be
with one yeah before okay so you got no
problem
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible